[Musique]
bonjour à vis de vous retrouver pour ce
nouveau numéro de 7,8 échos le magazine
consacré à l'actualité économique de
notre territoire sans plus tarder voici
le sommaire à saint quentin en yvelines
un tiers des chefs d'entreprise sont des
femmes pourquoi des sites est de devenir
entrepreneur mais aussi quels sont les
obstacles rencontrés
c'est le dossier de ce numéro et pour en
parler nous recevons emmanuel plutôt
président de l'association créactive
experts comptables ou encore commissaire
aux comptes ces professions aide chaque
jour les milliers d'entreprises sur
notre territoire un secteur qui ne
connaît pas la crise et qui a fait
découvrir ses atouts à des lycéens lors
d'un événement annuel aux chaînés un
atelier citoyen à voisins le bretonneux
sur le projet de loi de finances des
entreprises ont encore quel est l'impact
économique des offres airbnb dans les
yvelines
nous ferons un point sur le reste de
l'actualité économique
mais avant de développer tous ces titres
ouvrons ce magazine avec un chiffre 10
millions 1,2 euros c'est le montant que
la région ile de france va investir pour
soutenir trois projets industriels
innovants annonce faite dans le cadre du
programme smart région initiative
parmi les projets l'ordinateur le plus
puissant du monde sera développé sur le
site bull
atos aux clayes-sous-bois 5 millions
d'euros sont alloués au développement de
ce super calculateur quantique
cela permettra la création de 100
nouveaux emplois et on va continuer à
parler chiffres avec ces professions qui
recrutent au long de l'année
les experts-comptables ou encore les
commissaires aux comptes offrent des
salaires attractifs et des perspectives
d'évolution qui sont la plupart du temps
méconnu par les plus jeunes
c'est dans ce cadre qui était organisée
une journée pédagogique aux chaînés ou
servant du mari pannetrat numéro 10
partisans d'un samsung est tellement
jugement
en france 250 mille experts comptables
et pourtant ce métier est encore mal
connue casser les préjugés de cette
profession c'était tout l'enjeu de cette
journée destinée aux élèves de lycées et
de bts
on entend toujours que bâle comptable
c'est celui qui est pas beau qu'un pull
horrible avec sa calculette
mais voilà c'est une image a changé
cette image de personne réservée et qui
reste dans sa petite pièce ça colle pas
du tout à notre profession le salaire
est attractif en moyenne en expert
comptable en début de carrière gagne 29
mille euros bruts par an un commissaire
aux comptes 35000 euros et le secteur ne
connaît pas la crise
on recrute beaucoup les besoins au
niveau national sont de l'ordre de dix
mille personnes par an et si on regarde
simplement au niveau du département
l'île de france
on peut considérer qu'il ya à peu près
un millier de jeunes qui rejoignent au
cabinet chaque année pour faire
connaître ses atouts une convention a
été signée avec un lycée de saint
germain en laye une première en ile de
france
les élèves vont pouvoir accéder à une
base de données professionnelles
soixante dix mille documents sont à leur
disposition il ya toute la jurisprudence
il peut utiliser ce terme là qu'ils vont
découvrir autrement qu'en classe quand
ils vont être devant leur micro
ordinateurs qui vont pouvoir aller
chercher des documents qui sont
désormais mis à leur disposition et donc
ils vont pouvoir analyser cette
jurisprudence pour des questions qui
leur seront posées plus tard des
professions du chiffre au coeur de tous
les secteurs d'activité en france les
experts comptables et les commissaires
aux comptes aide chaque jour deux
millions d'entreprises
ouvrons à présent notre dossier
thématique consacré à l'entrepreneuriat
féminin sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines depuis ces dernières
années des structures se sont mises en
place pour permettre aux femmes de
devenir entrepreneur des réseaux pour
améliorer la parité se sont également
créés au sein de grands groupes comme
airbus
reportage
femme et chef d'entreprise en france
elles sont environ 30% avoir lancé leur
activité un chiffre identique sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
qui progresse chaque année
parmi les raisons qui poussent les
femmes à devenir leur propre chef
l'indépendance ou encore la perspective
d'augmenter ses revenus règle au rec est
une jeune société destinée à recycler
des déchets non recyclables pour en
faire un matériau qui peut remplacer le
bois à sa tête
hugo line solaire un projet d'activité
industrielle mûrement réfléchie depuis
deux ans et pourtant sa dirigeante a dû
essuyer quelques remarques défavorable
ce qui est le plus sensible on va dire
c'est cette sensation d'être un peu
infantile is est un petit peu
réduite à quelqu'un qui fait qu'ils
essayent de se lancer sans avoir
vraiment
d'armes d'arguments solides malgré ces
déconvenues
hugo line solaire a souhaité devenir
entrepreneur pour défendre avant tout
des valeurs de travail et de
collaboration entre prendre avec toute
la responsabilité que ça représente
l'autonomie ni le travail d'isolement
aussi c'est c'est quelque chose de
compliqué à gérer les femmes sont
peut-être plus prudentes plus
raisonnable en général je ne sais pas en
attendant c'est quand même un challenge
à la fois personnelle et professionnelle
donc voilà je j'espère que je vais
effectivement concilier toutes mes vies
dans ce projet là et c'est un métier
un défi qu'elle va tenter de relever
avec le soutien du ski cube l'incubateur
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines suit de
près les femmes de notre territoire qui
souhaitent devenir entrepreneur entre
l'idée que l'envi que peuvent avoir
certaines personnes et la concrétisation
du projet certains contraintes d'ordre
familial par exemple viennent parfois
freiner voire complètement stopper ce
projet qui aurait pu qui aurait pu
n'être donc à nous peut-être de faire
tomber un certain nombre de barrières
donner des clés supplémentaires pour
accompagner ces femmes qui peuvent avoir
envie d'entreprendre qui vont
des facilités à concrétiser donc à nous
d'intervenir sur le sujet ces dernières
années les associations pour accompagner
les femmes entrepreneurs se sont
multipliées entrepreneuriat au féminin
mampreneurs ou encore créactive à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines de gros
groupes ont également mis en place des
réseaux internes pour promouvoir la
diversité et notamment la parité c'est
le cas d'airbus avec balance for
business créé il y a deux ans et demi
c'est 4000 adhérents partout dans le
monde dont ils y sont essentiellement de
bénévoles gens qui mènent des actions
pour sensibiliser sur la motricité
le nombre de femmes chez airbus soit
présent 17%
il ya des actions qui sont menées pour
améliorer ces chiffres notamment au
niveau de recrutement de cadres et des
ingénieurs des travailleurs dont ceux
d'al un objectif de 30% de recrutement
elle 20% tous les logiciels mais sachant
naturellement que compétence reste s'il
existe encore de nombreuses marches à
gravir les mentalités évoluent et les
structures se multiplient pour permettre
aux femmes entrepreneures de devenir les
leaders de demain et pour aller plus
loin emmanuel plus tôt nous a rejoints
sur ce plateau bonjour alors vous êtes
la présidente de l'association a créé
active association qui rassemble 130
femmes chefs d'entreprise et porteuses
de projets à saint quentin en yvelines
alors première question est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dresser un état des lieux
justement de l'entreprenariat féminin
sur notre territoire alors sur le
territoire comme ailleurs les femmes se
lancent de plus en plus dans l'aventuré
de l'entrepreneuriat la différence si on
peut en voir une entre les femmes et les
hommes c'est que les femmes ont tendance
à créer leur propre emploi et non pas
une entreprise avec des salariés ca ca
c'est général pour des raisons diverses
et variées donc au sein de l'association
on a d'abord des femmes qui créent leur
emploi parfois après un parcours de
chômage qui les oblige à chercher une
autre solution
et puis parfois après un burnout parfois
par envie lointaine de créer leur
entreprise
là les orientations les raisons pour
lesquelles elles vont se lancer sont
très variés alors on a l'impression que
les femmes entrepreneurs doivent
travailler plus dur que les hommes
pourquoi alors là où l'association a été
créée pour aider les femmes à créer leur
entreprise à plus de 10 ans maintenant
la situation est bien différente
aujourd'hui de nouveau statut de nouveau
régime nous permettent de le faire plus
facilement la différence
s'il y en a une au delà de la difficulté
à aller trouver des clients et ça c'est
vrai pour les hommes comme pour les
femmes c'est peut-être que les femmes -
cette tendance à vouloir développer à
investir à prendre des risques et on le
voit d'ailleurs dans des organismes des
institutions tommy lee accompagne les
chefs d'entreprise il ya la couveuse
bg e qui aide les personnes à créer leur
entreprise en phase de test qui voient
principalement des femmes grande
majorité de femmes et en parallèle le
sky cube la maison de l'entreprise de
saint quentin en yvelines sur la partie
financement pour aider justement à
démarrer une activité voire majorité des
hommes
donc on voit bien que risque visiblement
n'est pas quelque chose de féminin et
pour encore une fois ex raisons elles
créent leur emploi mais ne vont pas
forcément au delà notre difficulté en
fait c'est que dans l'entreprise ans
l'association pardon on a que quasiment
des femmes qui n'ont pas de salarié on
aimerait avoir des femmes du territoire
qui sont à la tête d'entreprises
importants de tpe ou même de pme et qui
peuvent montrer qu' on peut développer
sans prendre forcément de risques mais
elles ne viennent pas l'association et
c'est toujours une déception de ne pas
les voir ce que j'aurais changé
justement pour que qui ait plus de
femmes justement à la tête de pm par
exemple je pense que les aider déjà à se
développer donc grandir commercialement
c'est un premier pas la problématique
c'est d'abord se payer soit avant
d'envisager investir dans un salarié
la recette investir dans un salarié
permet de se développer de façon plus
importante mais est toujours ce premier
pas qui est déjà de faire en sorte que
son entreprise soit florissante et nous
les femmes qu'on peut aider et
accompagner au sein de l'association
c'est d'abord leur problématique
embauchés ne vient que beaucoup plus
tardivement donc je pense que tout ce
qu'il peut se faire en termes de
conférences de retour d'expérience des
changes avec justement des femmes qui
ont déjà sauté le pas comment on fait
justement pour pour pour venir dans
votre association
alors l'association n'a que des fermes
adhérentes puisque c'était l'objet
de l'association au démarrage sur le
site internet kreactive point org
il y a la possibilité d'adhérer il ya
tous les rendez vous mensuel et on en a
quatre différents pour se retrouver dans
des formats qui vont nous aider
différemment soit en recevant de
l'information soit en pouvant échanger
sur un sujet soit en apprenant des
adhérentes elle même donc tout est sur
le site internet et toutes les soirées
choses importantes sont vertes aussi aux
hommes et aux non adhérentes puisque on
est adhérente
en tant que femmes porteuses de projets
ou entrepreneurs et on aime bien le mot
entrepreneur entrepreneurs avec un e
bien sûr avec un peu et tout homme ou
personnes extérieures à l'association
qui s'intéressent à la conférence
mensuelle eux nous rejoindre la seule
chose c'est que ce sera paris gratuits
on lui fera payer une petite part ses
passions 10 euros mais c'est ouvert
l'association est ouverte quand elle
organise des moments d'échangés et des
moments d'information merci
emmanuel plutôt d'avoir apporté votre
éclairage sur ce thème merci à vous
l'île de france qui ambitionne de
devenir la première smart régions
européennes ou encore des ateliers
citoyens autour du projet de loi de
finances des entreprises s'est tout de
suite dans l'actualité économique en
bref faire remonter les bonnes idées sur
le projet de loi de finances des
entreprises c'était l'objectif de
l'atelier organisé le 23 novembre
dernier à voisins le bretonneux que
député yvelinois jean-noël barrot doit
en effet rendre ses propositions le 10
décembre au ministre de l'économie les
produits des pannes dont on dispose
aujourd'hui
sont suffisants pour permettre aux
français d'avoir une exposition à ces
placements financiers qui parfois leur
permettre de constituer le
un petit patrimoine pour la retraite
c'est la première question et en face il
ya bien évidemment les entreprises qui
pourraient utilement bénéficier de ces
fonds de ces investissements que
pourraient faire les ménages pour se
développer pour innover pour créer des
emplois
l'île de france souhaite devenir la
première smart régions d'europe
une révolution digitale qui devrait
permettre d'améliorer la qualité de vie
des franciliens 40 millions d'euros
supplémentaires vont notamment être
investis pour aider les départements à
déployer le très haut débit
airbnb se veut plus transparent la
plateforme de location de logements
entre particuliers vient de lancer le
portail data ville
on peut y retrouver le nombre d'annoncés
ou encore le revenu annuel médian d'un
hôte dans la commune sur le territoire
de saint quentin en yvelines guyancourt
arrive en tête des villes qui ont le
plus d'annonce dans les yvelines depuis
un an 53 mille personnes ont choisi de
réserver leur logement via airbnb avec
un impact économique de 40000 euros
ces numéros touche bientôt à sa fin mais
avant voyons ensemble les rendez vous
économiques qui vous attendent
le ski cuba guyancourt organise un
atelier intitulé et booster votre
croissance il se déroulera lundi 4
décembre de 9 heures à 11 heures
inscription sur le site www.skype.com
une conférence sur les enjeux techniques
et sociétaux de la ville de demain sera
organisée jeudi 7 septembre à l'estac à
montigny le bretonneux une conférence
intitulée et des éco quartier à la ville
intelligente qui aura lieu de 18 heures
à 20 heures inscription à l'adresse mail
qui s'affiche en bas de votre écran
voilà c'est la fin de ce numéro merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve mardi 12
décembre pour un nouveau 7 8 et co
consacrée à la smart city à très bientôt
[Musique]